played that perfectly he was kind of backing
off Skinner but still cutting the shot off
but improving his time to react there too I
I always say for defenseman on two on ones
you've got to stay patient if he cheats if he
lunges towards Skinner it's luk goes down here
and that sets up PKA he scores Luke H slipped
and that allowed PKA in free for the seventh
straight game the devil surrender the opening
goal we'll watch right here and that's that's
unfortunate Luke Hughes goes down as he
and it happens that happens and petka
makes a great shot over the glove of vanich
to give the Sabers a lead but you know he he
gets skate caught in a run in the neutral
zone Skinner picks Brendan Smith off he's
into the offensive end drops it for tuck and
it's just behind Alex tuck where Luke Hughes
recovers three on two for New Jersey McLoud
drops it for Holtz he shoots Cy makes the
save McLoud sends it through the slot here's a
Luke Hugh rip Revenge score Alex hpz ties the
[Applause] [Music] game it happens there a big
part of this play Let's Take a look at our our
replay brought to you by the New Jersey Lottery
remember anything can happen in Jersey you see
the initial shop of the devil State hungry Around
the Net Holtz right in the blue paint there's the
save by comry pucks backhanded through the crease
and Luke Hughes sticks around finds that P Jack
Hughes the blind pass it was going to be perfect
broken up by power here's Mercer final 20 seconds
speeds in front two big Saves by conry shutting
the door on Meyer unbelievable Holtz moves Meer
shoots Cony got him again oh my his big body
his skill finally seems like it's starting to
take here in Buffalo as he's had a full offseason
to adjust to the saber system Greenway banging at
it devil down a stick it was Sean ther who lost
it and that allows Tage Thompson to walk in and
score as he deakes around vanichic Sabers back on
top make this play but because of his incredible
reach and size looks like he's going to run out
of room but watch this play as he's below the goal
line pulls it from his backhand to his forehand
right here and still has the reach to be able to
poke that puck into the empty net toley will come
out of the box 2 minutes from now and that's when
the devil's power play will start Casey midat
won the face off so Buffalo starts forward four
on four it's taken away by jeser Brat he has
Hughes with him brat goes in he scores put it
right through the five hole of Kory and it's tied
at [Applause] two and Agility from jper Brad as
the Sabers can't handle a puck they turn it over
it looks like a one brat says I'm going to just
go full board to the net the quick opening up of
the five hole and slides it underneath comry to
tie this hockey game up Devils 0 for one on the
power play today they've had six shots on the
power play just haven't gotten anything past Eric
comry yet another good shift by this Devil's Force
line Hughes lost it Alex tuck is the beneficiary
in on the break van comes up big that's a huge
save on a real good sniper in Tuck he's had
a little bit of a slow start to his season
and that's where Luke Hughes has to balance that
out now McLoud heading the other way he changes
directions Holtz wants it passes behind him and
intercepted just was a tough play y I know you
don't want to take away his skill and creativity
middle stat down low vanich got a p to it and the
rebound served wide Skinner was denied on the
first chance Skinner's got it again Vex there
Meer couldn't connect ended up on top of comry
now it's wide open going the other way and vanage
denies Genson another huge Vex save and it's sent
forward Alex tuck as middle stat trailing him tuck
finds middle stat moving it through the slot and
that bounce just wide a wrap around Skinner van
a check says no rebound still there and VTech
van finds it it was a 4-1 win for Ottawa that
night it was Ottawa okay I got that you were
on that ball blasted just wide of goal here's
T in front kicked Away by comry on a wicked fast
[Applause] reaction cousins in the corner his pass
to the Blue Line picked off by Eric haa haa in
shorthanded for the lead backhander he [Applause]
scores Eric Cola puts the devil's the head with a
shorty holla let's holla because that
was a beauty first it starts in his
Zone with a great read as cousins tries
to get it back to Rasmus do darene but
it's intercepted and anticipated
by Eric Holla clearcut Breakaway
you see that forehand pulls that all the
way across the backand and goes top shelf
delene gliding It Forward playing it
into space where Alex tuck was best
position tuck rolls off a check
feeds the Blue Line Skinner rips
it Holtz and Bastion combined to
block the shot Dalene triggers and
scores Alex tuck was setting a screen in front
Rasmus delene Rockets home his first of the year
the puck gets right back to Buffalo there's the
block and it comes right back to the point they
slide it over to do he gets all of it he whips
this Puck off of Bastion stick too yeah I think
it might got a little watch watch this changes
Direction goes up over the shoulder off the leg
so remainder of that period we'll see
how quickly or if he is back here for
the third Tage Thompson Eric Holla on the
opening draw period three a minute left on
the power play here's Jack again needs his
brother Jack gets it back Jack Hughes shoots
score Hughes threw it on to fly May ATT tit it
home either way the devil's lead amount of Zone
time on this Devil's power play and a couple of
good chances looking to made some saves Savers
do a good job of desperation around their net
but this time Jack Hughes up top you had some
TI penalty Killers it might have hit I think
it might have deflected off the defenseman
Eric Johnson stick I think it just went clean
all the way in maybe not Skinner who's not an
overly big guy as well so maybe the impact
wouldn't have been his batt Puck takes it
bounce right to Greenway he shoulders in kicks
sa vanage Puck is dropped down to Dylan cousins
he cuts back to the slot cousins shoots that's
just wide of goal dangerous move from cousins
he's got a big body short side it goes in Dylan
cousins sneaks it inside of vanich and ties the
game cutting to the middle missed a chance in
there right here well vanich can't believe it
because he looks like he's pretty pretty snug
to that left post I don't know how it squeezes
through just finds a little hole one more look
from the overhead angle yeah somehow bounced off
the side [Applause] 44 game neither team is led
by more than a goal at any point tonight we've
been tied up at 1-1 22 33 and now 44 ball
shot deflected score Eric Holland does it
[Applause] [Music]
again all starts with j for Bratt again his
his quickness his ability to escape in tight
quarters you see he spins around gets
to Marino real nice play by John Marino
quickly with the One Touch pass to get it
over to ball and the quick shot no wind
up get it through Sabres have been in the
lane blocking a lot of shots doing a good
job and somehow that thing weak door
with 5 Seconds pant to the front the
cloud tapping at it middle stat brings it
behind but there is the horn Devils win 54